the most comfortable men's boxers and
t-shirts you'll ever find are at leisure
of NYC their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers
feel as light as air and their silky
smooth supima cotton crewneck t-shirts
are amazing I love them you'll get 15
off with code Pacman at davidpackman.com
NYC I hope everybody had a good Memorial
Day weekend if you live in the United
States and you uh had a day off on
Monday you know I received many emails
over the weekend about the debt ceiling
and the bill that may have been reached
to avoid defaulting on U.S debt and many
of you were saying David why haven't you
been covering this why aren't you
covering this and it is true other than
I believe it was just one story on the
world famous award-winning bonus show I
have not spoken about the debt ceiling
debate controversy whatever you want to
call it and that has not been by
accident it's been on purpose and I want
to explain to you why and then I want to
hear from you does this make sense or
should I have been talking about it all
along now as a reminder the debt ceiling
is the legal limit on how much the
federal government can borrow to pay its
bills and importantly it has nothing to
do with new spending when we talk about
the debt ceiling we're talking about
borrowing to honor prior obligations
already approved by Congress so when
people want to debate well we should
allow the U.S to default because I'm
against the inflation reduction act or
whatever the case may be this is not
about debating new spending this is
about meeting obligations for already
approved spending and there are four
reasons that I have made the deliberate
choice and they all have to do with
respect for you in the audience four
reasons why I haven't been covering this
now first of all
the same thing happens every time and
this alone isn't a reason not to talk
about something things in politics will
happen more than once or at least
they'll happen almost identically more
than once but every time the debt
ceiling is reached and that happens
regularly because the government runs a
deficit you see Republicans threatening
to block its increase unless they get
concessions from Democrats they talk
about writing checks we can't cash they
talk about spending cuts they talk about
policy issues and it creates drama and
uncertainty but it is mostly a political
stunt
and I'm being clear here from the point
of view of Republicans talking about
defaulting Republicans know that the U.S
can't actually be allowed to default on
its debt because it would be
catastrophic to both the American
economy and to the reputation of
Republicans now if they could get away
with it with somehow Democrats getting
blamed maybe they would go for it but
they also know it would be bad for many
of their constituents to allow the U.S
to default and that they would get at
least some of the blame if not all so
they eventually cave and they agree to
raise the debt ceiling sometimes it's at
the last minute uh after a temporary
extension it's the same routine time and
again so it's happened many many times
and it is happening now secondly it's
all bad for the American people and what
I mean by that is not the defaulting
that might happen which would of course
be bad but the debt ceiling debate is
bad for the American people as a
narrative and a storyline it's not only
pointless it's also harmful it wastes
time and resources that could be spent
on actual important issues like new
infrastructure programs or getting
people Health Care climate change it
undermines The credibility and the
stability of the United States as a
borrower and a leader in the world the
more we publicize this absurd Antiquated
retro grade system which gets us to
these debt ceiling debates in the first
place the Dumber we look on the global
stage it's unnecessary it creates
volatility and risk in the financial
markets that hurts everybody
even people not in the markets just
straight up consumers it increases the
cost of borrowing for the government
that adds to the debt burden even more
in the long run and according to some
estimates the debt ceiling crises of
2011 and 2013 actually pushed interest
rates up somewhere between half a point
and two points costing taxpayers
billions of dollars so I don't want to
participate in worsening that situation
number three they eventually come to an
agreement despite the theatrics and the
grandstanding and the brinkmanship and
the entire thing both parties know
sooner or later you're going to have to
raise the debt ceiling and what they try
to get in the meantime is screen time
which I'll get to or concessions which
may or may not actually make any sense
they they can't afford to let the US
default on its obligations which could
trigger a financial meltdown a potential
recession they also don't want to face
backlash from voters at the end of the
day and from businesses who would suffer
in such a scenario so they strike a deal
it involves some minor concessions or
compromises the concessions or
compromises aren't significant enough to
say that's why it was good that they
were holding out and it fundamentally
changes nothing
about the fiscal situation or the
underlying situation in which we find
ourselves and lastly it's an attempt for
politicians to cynically get attention
during negotiations look at how many
stories there were about McCarthy's
heading to the White House to meet with
Biden and then they're sitting there the
debt ceiling debate is not actually
about fiscal responsibility the way
Republicans love to claim it's not
really about Economic Policy either
because the policies that get us to this
situation every however many months also
aren't being discussed in any serious
way it's about posturing and messaging
can I get a meeting with the president
can I as a republican accuse Democrats
of being fiscally irresponsible
everybody's trying to score points with
the base and attack their opponents and
I guess get some leverage to maybe get
some extra concessions or Advance their
agenda somewhere else some Republicans
have been trying to link the debt
ceiling to blocking the infrastructure
plan or reversing some Biden executive
orders so the reasons that I haven't
covered it are because in order to cover
it in the way that it is mostly being
covered I have to insult my Audience by
pretending that there is something
different going on than the exact same
thing that always goes on and it becomes
a distraction from more important urgent
matters that affect our lives and our
future now I won't deny
if the U.S did default on its debt and
did not raise the debt ceiling it would
be now not only globally chaotic it
would start to affect individuals who
are waiting on certain government
payments and in other situations I don't
deny that but the point is I don't
believe that that's actually at risk of
happening for any significant period of
time more than a few days at the end of
the day what could I possibly add to the
normal debate about the debt ceiling
this segment is the real analysis which
is it's an analysis of the way that the
debt ceiling is discussed the way that
the debt ceiling debate
is portrayed in media and used cynically
by our elected officials but there's
really nothing for me to add to that
this is the real analysis agree or
disagree I want to hear from you and I
haven't been covering it fundamentally
out of respect for my audience let's
talk about the truth about men in
women's sports now listen the truth is
what we're talking about here is trans
women in athletics that's the issue the
right has made this into an issue and
they call it Boys in girls sports or men
in women's sports what we're talking
about is trans women born biologically
male in women's sports now the reason
I'm going to do this today
is I want to have one clip to point to
when people call in and call in and ask
me about this it's not a super
interesting issue to me because I don't
think it is even remotely a super
important issue but we will get to that
the right has been talking about this
endlessly Trump and others regularly get
Applause when they say we will ban men
from women's sports
okay here's just one example of trumpet
CPAC I could play a thousand of these
clips of different Republicans talking
about this but this is the gist of how
they discuss it I will revoke every
Biden policy promoting the chemical
castration and sexual mutilization
utilization how are you
and ask Congress to send me a bill
prohibiting child sexual mutilation in
all 50 states
that should be easy
and we will keep men out of women's
sports
big big big Applause line all right so
what is the deal with so-called men in
women's sports is it an issue sure it's
an issue think about it this way and
we're going to put up like a flow chart
here you've got all issues and then you
have specifically issues related to
gender and sexuality which are a
fraction of that and then within that
you know lgbtq plus you've got trans
issues within that that's a slice and
then within trans issues you know you
you've got
um mental health component you've got
um uh other uh Health elements like for
example
um you know hormone therapy and uh
gender affirmation all these okay and
then you've got like discrimination
related issues within trans issues
within gender and sexuality within all
issues and then within discrimination
related trans issues we have sports
issues and then under sports issues it's
trans women in sports issues and then
within that it's Sports where muscle
mass confers and Advantage issues so
let's not pretend that the issue is
bigger than it is okay so then they get
to usually a discussion about fairness
now when they talk about fairness
remember they don't care about trans men
in men's sports they also don't really
care about trans women in women's
leagues in chess or shooting
or archery or curling curling has men's
women's and co-ed or equestrian uh even
in golf I mean driving distance is
absolutely a factor in golf but like
even in golf this isn't a big issue
sailing which is already co-ed darts
bowling right so we're talking about
some sports we're talking about
basketball weight lifting wrestling
rugby track and field often comes up
swimming is one that's gotten a lot of
attention there are three or four
so-called solutions that are sometimes
mentioned when we talk about a trans
women in women's sports one view is Ban
trans women from women's sports it
raises the question of what do you do
with the one percent of folks who are
born intersex okay but you basically say
we're not going to allow trans women to
compete in women's leagues all right
second option allow trans women in
women's sports period or allow trans
women in women's sports if they have a
doctor
that signs off that they have
um you know achieved they've been on
hormone treatments long enough that a
doctor determines that there is no
advantage or you know we have to find
the right words but the idea is a doctor
signs off that this is an individual who
should be allowed to compete in women's
leagues okay fourth thing that's
mentioned is have a separate League or a
separate division specifically for trans
women
um and that's the way you deal with it
so let's first agree that we don't need
to worry about some sports as I already
mentioned we're really just concerned
with sports where this might be relevant
the first question is do trans women
actually have an advantage if you're
going to seriously discuss this you
first have to address the question do
trans women actually have an advantage
everyone assumes of course always in
every single one of these Sports the
real answer is sometimes and the reality
is that many trans women transition
early in adulthood sometimes they don't
undergo male puberty in the same way
that cisgender males do and end up being
indistinguishable from CIS women by any
casual Observer and there's not really a
concern there so with that group and
again we're subdividing subdividing to
really get to the core of this I don't
know that they
should be excluded from women's sports
league so if these early transition
trans women have no muscular Advantage
they may not have undergone male puberty
it seems they should be allowed to
participate without any issue based on
everything I've read
then there's the issue that a viewer
wrote to me about
basketball players are selected for
height
there are demographic groups that on
average are shorter they are already
underrepresented for example in
basketball so what about trans women who
are already smaller in stature due to
their genetics are they really a threat
to the Integrity of so-called women's
sports maybe that's another group that
should be allowed to participate without
much controversy so then we get to
what about trans women who have
undergone hormone therapy the data
suggests that after two years we're
talking about run let's talk about
running as a sport running after two
years of hormone therapy the average
Advantage for trans women in running is
12 now that's a bell curve and it would
overlap with the bell curve for
biologically born women 12 on average
means that many trans women after two
years of hormone therapy have no
advantage or actually have a
disadvantage if you understand how a
bell curve works and then of course
there would be some trans women who
after two years would have a bigger than
12 percent Advantage but the point here
is 12 is less than the variability
within the group of biologically born
women so that becomes a tough case to
also say ban all of them so the point
here is it's really easy and simple and
popular to the right and within the
culture War to say ban wet men in
women's sports if you actually want to
do the topic Justice
and talk about it like an adult and see
the nuance and the complexity of the
issue there are some real questions to
be figured out the the zoom out and
again this I I feel like this is the
most important part this is not the most
important issue now somebody will say
David my 14 year old little girl has
been training for softball for years and
they brought in a trans 14 year old girl
and uh that that trans girl hit a
thousand home runs and destroyed the
league okay let's figure that out let's
not pretend though that this is the
foremost issue facing America right now
that is worthy of the vitriol and the
hatred that's coming from the right and
also importantly let's not even pretend
that this is the biggest issue Under the
Umbrella of trans issues when we have
attempts to block gender affirming care
we have uh groups openly discriminating
we've got the bathroom stuff we've got
all these different things
I don't even believe for a second that
trans women in women's sports is the
biggest trans issue today
never mind one of the biggest issues in
the country
if my daughter in you know 15 years
imagine that Baruch Hashem she ends up
being really good at soccer and all of a
sudden half of the other team is trans
women am I going to what am I going to
think about that I don't know what I'm
going to think about it but what I do
know is I'm not going to go around
looking to insult people or deny anybody
rights that's for sure and that's the
starting point where we should all start
from and then we can figure out what it
is that should be done let me know your
thoughts of course all of these
discussions will be on our YouTube
channel which you can subscribe to at
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
if you are still looking for the perfect
Father's Day gift check this out guys
know that it can be tough to find good
boxers and t-shirts but the search can
end now because our sponsor Leisure of
NYC sells the most comfortable t-shirts
and boxers that your dad is ever going
to wear all boxer briefs by Leisure of
NYC are made with amazingly soft
moisture wicking viscose from bamboo
feels lightweight like air but it
doesn't Bunch up it's also better for
the planet Leisure of NYC also makes
these incredible supima cotton crew neck
t-shirts for men less than one percent
of men's Basics today are made with
supima cotton it's really the best out
there it just feels almost like Silk you
can let your dad walk around in a
scratchy t-shirt all day but come on you
can also treat him with the cloud soft
feel of supine cotton so that it'll
actually love the shirt these are always
my go-to shirts and boxers no other
company even comes close to the Comfort
they provide and all of their products
are fair trade and made sustainably go
to davidpackman.com
NYC and you'll get 15 off with the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below
folks let us not forget that the David
Pacman show is a community supported
program an audience supported program if
you missed yesterday's Memorial Day sale
on memberships we will extend it to you
even today just email info
davidpackman.com asking for the coupon
code we will get you the coupon code and
it will be a beautiful thing to take
advantage of this extraordinary discount
Newt Gingrich has admitted the
devastating reason that Trump will win
it's not devastating to Trump it's
devastating to the Republican Party
Laura Ingraham Fox News propagandist
interviewed Newt Gingrich about the
entrance of Republican Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis into the 2024 presidential
primary and Newt Gingrich points out uh
DeSantis is plenty smart but he's not
able to talk to people who might only
have a third fourth or fifth grade
education the way that Trump is now the
start of this clip is a clip of DeSantis
talking about the financial system and
the framing is hey great that DeSantis
is talking about that but does the
average voter even understand this it's
a funny premise and then Newt lays down
the humiliating reality about the
average Trump or republican voter at
this point in time
we will not be a free Society if major
financial institutions can do through
the economy uh what people could not
achieve Through The Ballot Box our
rights will be restricted uh will be the
end result and that's not healthy for a
free country
now nude and it's a good point but is it
can people grab onto that and kind of
understand Allah the contract with
America what that what is he getting at
there I mean will you and I know but can
the folks around the dinner table
understand that who are not into
politics
so this may seem like an odd comment but
I think that he's very very smart uh he
clearly did very well at Yale uh he is
uh clearly capable of thinking about Big
Ideas but you know Ronald Reagan was
probably equally smart but he also
understood that he had to communicate so
that every day folks understood it one
of Trump's great advantages is he talks
at a level where third fourth and fifth
grade educations can say oh yeah I get
that I understand it and in fact Trump
has now made the Republican Party The
Party of working Americans in a way that
probably hasn't been true for almost 100
years that's a bit of an exaggeration
but the point here is still an
interesting one uh so the challenge for
the Santa says take that interesting
sentence and figure out how do you boil
it down to a slogan and to a specific
thing I think it's fair to say and I
know this from the polling data we do at
the America's new majority project the
American people fear big business okay
so the truth is that what Newt Gingrich
is saying is maybe an inadvertent but
completely devastating burn of trump
supporters and it exposes the sad
reality of the Republican party today
you can frame what Newt said there in
two ways and they're very different you
can say the Republican party is now the
party of the working class and DeSantis
simply needs to hone his Yale education
to be more uh understandable and also
align more with that working class that
is now the bulk of the Republican party
or something or you can interpret that
as the average Republican voter is so
uninformed and so often ignorant that
you need to dumb things down so that
even an adult with a third grade
education could understand it one of
those two interpretations has a much
more negative connotation and it's the
second one I believe that the truth is
clear and this is not about Republicans
are dumb
this is about understanding realities
the Republican party has become a party
how can I say this that appeals to the
lowest common denominator
panders to ignorance and fear and
rejects facts and science they also dis
often dismiss any Nuance thought
as left-wing nonsense
and the party at the same time doesn't
want to invest in public education and
hasn't done so in many red States they
don't want to promote critical thinking
among its base especially in red states
where we know that the educational
outcomes are worse than in blue States
so as a result the party the Republican
party has alienated many of these
moderate independent educated voters who
are increasingly voting for Democrats
rather than Republicans those are folks
who value reason and competence over
rhetoric and Charisma and DeSantis
doesn't have Charisma either by the way
the data are not blurry or unclear or
gray it's crystal clear as far as
education and red versus blue States you
look at the top 10 states with the best
school systems they were all blue States
or our swing states that voted Biden in
2020. the reliably blue or swing but
voted Biden 2020 you look at the tensed
states with the worst school systems and
worst education they were all red states
that voted Trump in 2020. so this is a
reality
and whether you put a positive spin on
it like enrich does about the party of
the working people is now the Republican
party or you say this is an electorate
that has been dramatically dumbed down
by virtue of the policies they support
either way you have to recognize that
Democrats do have an edge over
Republicans when it comes to educational
attainment among American adults when
you look at
um bachelor's degree or higher 41
percent of Democrats have a bachelor's
degree or higher only 31 percent of
Republicans do that's a massive
difference if you look at high school
only high school diploma or less about a
third of Republicans have not gone
beyond high school diploma and some have
even a lesser education than that
compared to only 28 percent of Democrats
whose educational attainment is that low
and this is a gap that continues to
widen and it's widening among white
voters as well education influences
political preferences and behavior
DeSantis is trying to position himself
as a viable alternative to Trump in 2024
and he talks about his record handling
covet and he talks about we were worst
hit but we did really well and he's
endorsing the culture War agenda of what
woke goes to die in Florida and he's
restricting voting rights he's
restricting what teachers are allowed to
teach he's planning critical race Theory
and trans athletes and and allowing
permitless gun carry like he's doing all
of that stuff but Newt Gingrich is
getting to a devastating reality which
is that DeSantis at least so far and I
get it it's only been a few days but
he's been sort of campaigning much
longer than he's been an official
candidate DeSantis has not articulated
a clear and compelling message that
distinguishes him from Trump in a way
that will resonate with the broader
Republican electorate and Gingrich
accurately points out
DeSantis has to find some way to make
the case for himself it could be too
late and I know it's like he hasn't even
running been running for a week how is
it too late DeSantis may have already
alienated many voters with what happened
between the time that Trump announced
and the time that DeSantis announced and
now you've got Tim Scott and Nikki Haley
and all these folks taking just little
percentages of the electorate DeSantis
needs a path to more than 50 percent
it's either by taking everyone else's
support including some of Trump's or
growing the base by so much that he
brings in people who were who were not
as of today likely Republican primary
voters if he can find people who today
are saying I probably won't vote in the
primary and get them to say oh now I'm
interested in voting in the primary
that's another path forward I don't
really see his ability to do it and he's
already talking about pardoning Trump
which I don't know that's going to help
him very much all right so let's talk
about that on the clay and buck show
newly minted after his disastrous
Twitter announcement 2024 Republican
presidential candidate Ron DeSantis was
on the clay and buck show and he wanted
to uh address the issue of Pardons and
he says no pardon is off the table up to
and including Donald Trump this is a
couple minutes long let's get into it a
lot of interesting stuff here abandon a
big part of being president is pardon
powers do you think the January 6
defendants deserve to have their cases
examined by a Republican president and
if Trump let's say gets charged with
Federal offenses and you are the
president of the United States would you
look at potentially pardoning Trump
himself based on the evidence that might
emerge of those charges
the doj and FBI have been weaponized we
see that we see it in a variety of
contexts some of which you mentioned
some of it is the FBI going after
parents going to school board meetings
some of it's how they treat a pro-life
demonstrator how they don't go after
people that are attacking pro-lifers and
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
do on day one I will have folks that
will get together and look at all these
cases who people are victims of
weaponization or political targeting and
we will be aggressive at issuing parted
now some of these some of these cases
some people may have a technical
violation of the law but if there are
three other people who did the same
thing but just in a context like BLM and
they don't get prosecuted at all that is
uneven application of justice and so
understand the framing here and then
he'll get to the Trump part the framing
here is
we need Law and Order
but we can't allow people of different
political Stripes one to be prosecuted
and the other not like if you go after a
January 6th Rider but not a BLM person
if they did the same thing they should
both be prosecuted I agree the thing is
they're pretending like there's many
examples of that when in reality there
are not we're going to find ways where
that did not happen and then we will use
the pardon power and I will do that at
the front end you know a lot of people
wait until the end of the administration
to issue pardons uh we're gonna find
examples where web government's been
weaponized against disfavored groups uh
and we will apply relief as appropriate
but it will be done on a case-by-case
basis because I think you've got to make
sure that um because there's a whole
bunch of cases that don't necessarily
get headlines but if people are being
treated just because they don't get on a
TV or something they're being treated
disfavorably they need to have a fair
hearing as well and that could be from a
grandma who got arrested and prosecuted
too much all the way up to potentially
try himself is that fair to say when you
analyze what the charges might have been
brought on a federal level
I would say any example of disfavored
treatment based on politics or
weaponization uh would would be included
in that review no matter how small or
how yeah so that that's up to and
including Trump think about the argument
and the case DeSantis is making he wants
to be president he wants to be chosen
over Donald Trump to be president
Trump incited an insurrectionist Riot on
January 6th and rather than coming out
and saying the Republican party needs to
go in a different direction I condemn
what Donald Trump did in citing his
followers on January 6 but instead he
says I'd consider pardoning him I'd
consider pardoning him now let's put
aside the political calculation the
political calculation I've told you
before is he want the he being DeSantis
wants to find some path
to appeal to the people currently
supporting Trump so that they might vote
for him and his calculation is if I
condemn Trump's role in the riots and
the attempted coup I'm getting rid of
all the Maga the potential Maga support
So DeSantis has made the calculation
that he's not going to do that but let's
step back from the political this is a
very dangerous and irresponsible thing
for Rhonda Sanders to say he is
undermining the rule of law
and undermining the accountability of
public officials or excusing uh public
officials from accountability Trump is
facing multiple investigations including
for his role in citing the January 6
Riot his business dealings classified
information handling
pardoning Trump would send the message
that he's above the law and his actions
don't have consequences and it will only
embolden the extremist elements of the
base who participated in the riots or
who who supported them or thought that
they were a good thing DeSantis said he
would also consider pardoning rioters
writers himself saying well some of them
were it was a technical violation of the
law we call those violations of the law
and when you say well it was a technical
violation but it deserves a pardon
you're either saying they were Justified
actions or that they were trivial
actions and all that will do is
encourage more violence and encourage
the potential for another Insurrection
and it will also by the way just deepen
the polarization and the division in the
country DeSantis talks about oh I would
become a uniter or whatever he's saying
I will use pardon power to favor what he
sees as disfavored groups who were the
victims of political targeting it's the
same victim mentality again and again
and again and when the world sees this
they look at it and they say this United
States what are they doing over there
what are they doing and DeSantis is
echoing another mistake from American
history when President Gerald Ford
pardoned Richard Nixon after the
Watergate scandal that was a mistake
that eroded public trust in government
it weakened our moral Authority because
it said okay yeah Law and Order except
for some vague unification of the
country we're going to pardon Nixon I
think it was a mistake I think it is a
mistake to be talking already about
pardoning Donald Trump now in the
meantime Joe Biden was asked about
pardoning Trump he just laughed it off
[Applause]
all right
said that if he became president he
would pardon Trump where are you on the
idea of President pardoning Trump
[Applause]
Biden laughs and waves it off and this
is absolutely the right answer and by
the way I think this is better than
Biden even saying I will not pardon
Trump
because if Biden says I will not pardon
Trump that will be politicized Biden has
been handling this perfectly which is to
say anytime he's asked
I am not getting involved in any of that
I'm just not getting involved and even
the question would you consider
pardoning Trump you say yes I would well
obviously he wouldn't say yes you say no
I wouldn't people say well what if the
evidence showed it was politically
walking away
laughing and waving it off is the right
answer Biden should have nothing to do
with the prosecution of trump and I love
that he is staying out of it
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com join pacman.com
we appear to be approaching potentially
two more arrests of failed former
president Donald Trump first and
foremost is that Fannie Willis in
Georgia is stepping up security and
precautions for this next uh season so
to speak of announcing indictments that
will start in July and run through
September there is the belief that Trump
is getting indicted there but separately
there is a rolling stone article Trump's
lawyers warn him get ready to be
indicted by the feds the former
president has angrily complained in
response to predictions that if the
justice department is going to charge
him then what about Joe Biden what about
Joe Biden and the article says some of
Trump's lawyers and advisors have given
the former president an unwelcome if not
unexpected message in recent weeks you
should expect to get indicted this year
now we've talked about 4 about the
seemingly underailable train that is
Trump speeding towards the Republican
nomination and in those hypotheticals
the question about what could derail it
has mostly gone to if Trump gets
arrested and is so bogged down by
criminal cases that he quite literally
can't get out on the campaign Trail in
any substantive way it starts to affect
the Republican electorate and people who
currently say they would be voting for
Trump in the primary were today move on
to someone else maybe DeSantis or maybe
someone else uh but short of that Trump
seems to have an unobstructed path to
the nomination
and yet we now seem to be potentially
within months of trump getting arrested
two more times the article also says
several legal and political counselors
to Trump have bluntly informed him they
expect the justice department to charge
him in the criminal investigation into
his hoarding of Highly classified
documents following the end of his
presidency two sources familiar with the
matter tell Rolling Stone
this of course comes on the heels of
Trump's indictment by local prosecutors
in Manhattan in April for falsifying
business records later this summer
officials in Fulton County Georgia are
expected to make a decision about
whether or not to indict Trump
Trump's attorneys and confidants told
Trump that though they view the federal
investigation as BS they would be
surprised at this point if he wasn't
charged particularly for alleged
obstruction of justice and have urged
Trump to prepare for yet another
historic fight looks like they're going
for it one of the sources says people
close to the former president have
discussed with him what we think is
going to happen soon and how he and
everyone else needs to be ready for it
it would be crazy not to so there's two
things going on here one there are very
real political implications we are
quickly getting into the heat of a very
hotly contested Republican primary it
will be an unprecedented situation where
uh the current president will be running
for re-election that's Joe Biden against
a former president
who was already defeated by Biden and
then will be running again against him
unprecedented and you throw into the
middle of that already won maybe two
maybe a third arrest and it is going to
be complete in total chaos if we go
beyond the political implications
progress is slow but we are seeing some
progress now I still don't believe that
we are going to see Trump do a day of
prison or jail I don't think we're going
to see it in any of these cases
however
if you look at the degree to which this
has gone from this stuff should be
investigated to there are investigations
to we're talking to a grand jury to it's
looking like the grand jury wants to
convict you Trump has been arrested once
and maybe and may end up arrested three
times that is Major progress in seeking
to find uh justice for the alleged
wrongs of the Trump presidency so we
will be following the forthcoming
possibility of more arrests very closely
it is important to also understand that
while Trump seems to have an
unobstructed path to the nomination
unless multiple arrests take them off
the campaign Trail the so-called
anti-trump Republican movement seems to
be imploding let's talk about that next
there's a super interesting piece in
Politico magazine this piece is by
Jonathan Martin and it is called are the
and see Trump GOP forces meaning
Republican forces starting to implode a
mission control breakdown for the
DeSantis and smooth launch for Tim Scott
bowed ill for those hoping to thwart the
former president this entire article is
worth reading but I want to focus on a
couple of different aspects to this the
article asks Jonathan Martin asks will
this go down as the week that the grand
plan to deny Donald Trump the nomination
fell apart
for months high-level Republican
lawmakers donors and strategists eager
to block Trump have described in
separate conversations with me and end
game to the presidential primary when it
becomes clear in the early State and
National polling who is consolidating
support the most influential figures
with ties to the lagging candidates will
stage a sort of political intervention
and tell them it's time to quit and
rally to the strongest alternative to
Trump
such a plot always struck me as a bit
far-fetched for starters because
politicians aren't known for putting
party ahead of self interestingly it's
exactly what Democrats did in the
primary in 2020
back to Jonathan Martin yet the appetite
among Elite Republicans to move past
Trump was and is so immense I thought
there could at least be a do the right
thing effort yet as spring turns to
Summer traditionally the period where
presidential hopefuls consider whether
they're gaining traction this vision
seems more fantasy than real than
strategy in fact if Trump does emerge as
the GOP standard Bearer next year we'll
look back we will look back on this week
to grasp why just like in 2016 he was
able to take advantage of a divided
opposition Now understand the strategy
that is being laid out this is a
possible strategy
the idea would be okay
uh the Florida primary comes close and
imagine that it's Trump 55 and DeSantis
35 because it's his home state and the
other 20 or 10 percent is divided among
other candidates the idea would be
everyone other than DeSantis gets out
and says support DeSantis and maybe that
gets to sandus enough to beat Trump in
Florida in New Hampshire maybe Nikki
Haley's doing better other than Trump
and so even though Trump is winning in
New Hampshire everybody but Nikki Haley
gets out and says vote for Nikki Haley
or whatever it's not super realistic
the timing of it needs to be just so and
it's not clear that Republicans are
willing to do that but what is being
argued in this article is it's it's not
going to happen for other reasons and it
goes on to say the reasons are
desantis's muffed launch the fitting sad
trombone conclusion to a
pre-announcement period in which his
stock sagged
um
announcing his candidacy Monday in the
gym of his alma mater
uh John Charleston Southern University
Tim Scott matched desantis's Elon Musk
with John thune and Larry Ellison
um he also doesn't seem destined for
victory
and then there's Nikki Haley whose
campaign is totally Dead on Arrival
Etc the problem with the anti-trump
Republican movement right now is that
they're all failing very hard Nikki
Haley was never inspiring from the
beginning running basically an identity
campaign Vivek ramas Swami was never
really going anywhere
uh Tim Scott I mean again as I said
before it's not all about identity but
Republicans have two have for now for
two uh elections in a row presidential
elections in a row selected the guy who
was openly hostile to black and brown
people in his rhetoric if not policy
they're gonna say oh let's vote for a
black guy instead to represent us it
seems unlikely at the most base of Base
levels and then now the DeSantis launch
where DeSantis is trying to figure out a
way how can I kind of be there to pick
up the Maga voters but I don't really
want to attack Trump to explain to the
mega voters why they should support me
instead it's not a winning proposition
the launch was a disaster the only good
news for anybody other than Trump is
this chart that we're putting up on the
screen right now
the purple line at the top of your
screen is Trump's polling which as you
can see is down from 56 to 53 since the
santis announced
and on the other hand DeSantis is up
from 19 to 22. so we have seen a
three-point swing in polling in the
direction of DeSantis and away from
Trump since it became known that
DeSantis would be announcing if you look
at the very bottom
everyone else is failing okay you look
at Pence is down from six to three and
Haley is at one point was at six she's
down to four everybody else is just
peanuts peanuts peanuts whereas DeSantis
and Trump are the only ones really
embroiled in anything here so if there
is a path right now for anyone other
than Trump
I don't see it as being anybody but
DeSantis but it's not even June of the
year before the election yet there is
time if there is a big news making event
and in my mind the only possible event
would be Trump gets indicted and
arrested multiple times and is simply
unable to run can anything else change
this Republican primary let me know in
the comments
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
uh dozens of you over the Memorial Day
Weekend sending me these clips of Donald
Trump on the golf course giving a short
interview everybody's saying Trump looks
sick David something is clearly wrong
with Trump he's pale he's low energy his
everything about him just his face is
sagging and all these different things
I'm going to look at the clips let's see
what we have he also is a guest
addressing some issues about Ron
DeSantis
if you were on a debate stage with Ron
DeSantis what would you say to him what
would be your interactions with him
I don't know but they say he's not a
very good debater but maybe he is I
don't know we'll find out maybe we'll
find out
Because unless he gets close why would
anybody debate all right so Trump there
suggesting he might not even debate
DeSantis unless DeSantis gets close in
polling yeah I mean listen Trump doesn't
look good I think what's going on here
and I'm not trying to be funny or
disrespectful or anything is when Trump
doesn't have
the you know the the dyed hair perfectly
quaffed and perfectly for Trump is an
open to interpretation the spray tan the
suit the entire thing
Trump's an obese older guy and so this
is just what he looks like I think I
think it's that simple I don't know that
Trump is sick necessarily here's another
clip and Trump does seem worse in this
one where he goes after DeSantis for
being disloyal are you angry Mr
President that Ron DeSantis entered the
race
he's a very disloyal person because he
was dead
for jobs and I endorsed him and he went
up many points he was 30 points down at
least maybe more than that he was dead
so I think he's very disloyal but I
don't care look Paul just came out in
Iowa he saw the one that just came out a
little couple of minutes ago I'm leading
by
30 or 40 points uh I don't mind that at
all but no I think he's very disloyal
but he's got no personality if you don't
have personality politics is a very hard
business so Hey listen I actually agree
with this analysis desantis's
personality is just so uh the opposite
of what anybody would ever want to see
at a dinner party or in the in the Oval
Office
um that I I it's obviously it's not just
that he's also a dangerous authoritarian
wannabe I think Trump is actually right
about that Trump doesn't look good he
looks exhausted he looks pale you know
the eyes are almost swollen shut I agree
I think uh it's more of it his energy
seems to be suffering does he have what
it takes
for this campaign particularly if he's
trying to beat off one or one indictment
two indictments potentially three
indictments I think there are some real
questions there but not a great
interview for the failed former
president I have recently been called
far left by the polyamorous
cuban-american streamer Stephen Kenneth
Destiny benell Goranson II
um in all seriousness polyamorous Cuban
American these are jokes Destiny's a
friend of mine but a bunch of people
sent me a clip during which the streamer
Destiny is I guess talking about the
space now for those who aren't aware of
how streaming content works most of
what's on the screen is a video game of
some kind I I can't tell if this is
Grand Theft Auto or Tetris or what it is
and then in the bottom right corner
that's the guy who we're going to hear
from Destiny talking here's what he had
to say let's listen and then we will
discuss
keep saying like The Young Turks and
David Pacman but these guys are like
progressives they're like yeah logical
Spectrum I would say that like Stephen
Crowder is pretty far right but the
daily wire Stephen Carter's further to
the right than the dealer but the daily
wire represents a solid center-right
conservative mouthpiece center-right
conservative establishment uh not
establishment I'm sorry center right
conservative alternative media is the
daily wire there is nothing like the
closest thing that would be Center left
my guess would be based on a little bit
of her like pod save America or
something but like otherwise like
alternative left media space like
everybody else is way to loved The Young
Turks is not Center left they are far
left David Pacman is barely Center left
but more far left you can't say The
Young Turks are Center left whoa
so all right there's some interesting
stuff here now the real story here and
this goes back to Mike why am I talking
about this I'm talking about it because
it's funny but also I'm talking about it
because I had this conversation when I
was on Lex Friedman a few weeks ago I
guess it's been almost a month it's
crazy
um we had this conversation about where
is the left on the political spectrum
and the difference is like I'm to Joe
Biden's left and but you know I'm
certainly to the right of socialists the
way socialists are normally placed on
the political Spectrum although I might
take issue with that the real story in
hearing Stephen Kenneth Destiny benel II
say this is that Destiny and I agree on
almost everything so it's hard to
imagine an analysis in which I'm far
left and Destiny is not fall left far
left call it what you want like either
neither of us is far left or we're both
far left and I I don't know if Destiny's
being provocative or you know whatever
the case may be I'm a progressive Social
Democrat advocating for some way to get
everybody health care although I'm
flexible on exactly how we do it a
living wage campaign Finance reform we
need Environmental Protections we need
to use progressive taxation to reduce
inequality and fund social program these
are not number one these aren't radical
or Fringe ideas these are mainstream
ideas popular among most Americans if
they are fairly polled and the default
sort of northern European social
democracy so to say that that's far left
doesn't seem super accurate it is also
true that as opposed to some on the
so-called far left
I'm not a dogmatic ideologue where I
blindly follow a party line or get
involved in tribal identity and that
makes me like Destiny I think he also
doesn't do that I've been critical of
the democratic party I've been critical
of the Progressive Movement I've been
critical of corporate media when it is
appropriate like destiny I also
regularly engage with people from
different parts of the political
Spectrum different backgrounds I've done
the Joe Rogan show twice did Lex
Friedman I was on the Patrick Bet David
podcast the Trump supporter Etc
what you also have to understand is that
there's a movement in the U.S the right
wing that calls what I just described
far left I think that they're wrong
there is a movement in the U.S and
globally socialists that call My Views
Center left I put myself between Center
left and far left because we're sort of
forced into this political Spectrum but
the most important the funniest thing
about all of this is that Destiny's
views and My Views line up almost
exactly on most issues as far as I know
he supports many of the same policies I
do he once praised me as a left-wing
commentator whose reasonable and
intellectually honest so if I'm far left
I think Destiny is also far left now I
will say one other thing and this is
speculation okay and I'll talk to
Destiny anytime he can't I guess go on
my twitch streams because he's banned on
Twitch and it's a whole mess but I'd
love to talk about this
Destiny might label me as far left
because he may be going through a period
of distancing himself from the
progressive wing of the left and he may
want to appeal to a more Centrist
audience I don't know if that's the case
I'm speculating I also think that
there's a false equivalence between even
comparing the daily wire to the David
packman show because the daily wire is a
right-wing propaganda Outlet
that is out there to spread
disinformation and to fear monger
on a daily basis and they are funded by
millionaire donors who have a vested
interest in maintaining the status quo
and undermining democracy the David
Pacman show is actually an independent
media platform without any of these
millionaire donors certainly we have
people who have a membership who happen
to be millionaires but we don't have
millionaire donors funding Us in the way
that the daily wire does and there's
really no way to even talk about the
daily wire in the David packman show in
the same sentence or on the same
Spectrum although he may just have been
talking about political alignment rather
than what the media Outlets represent so
to sum this up you know if if I'm far
left Destiny's far left it's either both
of us or neither of us and I thought it
was thought it was an interesting
comment we have a voicemail number that
number is 219 to David P here's someone
calling in with some suspicions about
what might have caused all of those
technical problems during the Ron
DeSantis Twitter spaces launch
uh from Cleveland I was just calling
because I think I know why Ron DeSantis
is having all of these technical
difficulties
um he must have gotten the covet vaccine
and so now that he is magnifying none of
his Tech works right um sort of like a
Be Kind Rewind situation for anyone who
saw that movie
um but no anyways I wanted to let you
know
that your Ron DeSantis is spot on I love
listening to it you do a lot of
Impressions but you do a really good
meatball so uh keep up the good work and
uh and uh can't wait to hear the next
show I I actually think that my Ron
DeSantis impression is bad I don't think
I think what I thought what was funny
about it was that it's bad what I do is
I basically try to move the discussion
back to my throat I can move to and and
I just try to sound whiny Florida is
where woke goes to die we're not going
to allow these people to come here and
tell us that adverbs and pronouns and
proper nouns are going to be we're just
not going to do it and that's why me
that's why I launched on Twitter spaces
alongside Elon Musk because he's for
free speech and I'm Banning books and so
it's just the natural progress I don't
think it's a good impression I thought
what was funny was how bad it was but uh
at least
at least one person likes it all right
folks this is serious
on the bonus show today
over the weekend producer Pat ran a half
marathon okay producer Pat collapsed at
the Finish Line not fed metaphorically
usually oh Trump collapsed people say oh
uh you don't literally mean that Pat
collapsed at the at the on the bonus
show Pat collapsed at the finish line
heat stroked blacked out next thing he
remembers is he woke up in an ice bath
and subsequently at the hospital this
happened to CNN's John Berman when he
ran a full Marathon a little while ago
producer Pat has been medically cleared
to be back on the bonus show he will
join us on the bonus show and we will
talk about it he says there's funny
things he said it was serious for a
little bit but that some funny things
also happened so
um we're going to discuss that on the
bonus show and more sign up at
joinpakman.com folks don't miss the
bonus oh the bonus show where you want
to make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad and if
you miss the Memorial Day discount code
email info davidpackman.com asking for
it we will get you that code don't miss
today's bonus show folks please
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors the most
comfortable men's boxers and t-shirts
you'll ever find are at leisure of NYC
their Ultra Soft bamboo boxers feel as
light as air and their silky smooth
supima cotton crewneck t-shirts are
amazing I love them you'll get 15 off
with code Pacman at davidpackman.com NYC